une image aussi étonnante que
démocratique les deux favoris à la
présidentielle qui sont également les
deux derniers présidents ghanéens ont
signé ce vendredi un pacte de paix cet
accord porte avant tout sur le respect
des futurs résultats du scrutin
présidentiel
un acte fort qui rassure les ghanéens
malgré un déploiement militaire liée à
des troubles dans la région de la volta
dans l'est du pays
je pense que l'élection va être un
succès nous nous attendons à ce que les
choses soient calmes même s'il y a des
sources de préoccupation dans certaines
régions en particulier dans la région de
la volta où nous avons appris qu'il y
avait eu une forte présence militaire
we want peace nous voulons la paix ils
font les élections lundi s'il vous plaît
tout le monde devrait aller voter pour
nana akufo addo
il est le numéro un est ce normal
ce lundi 17 millions de ghanéens sont
appelés à se rendre aux urnes pour des
élections regroupant scrutins
présidentiel et législatif treize
candidats briguent le poste de chef de
l'état
mais seulement deux d'entre eux semblent
être en mesure de remporter l'élection
l'actuel président du ghana nana akufo
addo vise un deuxième mandat consécutif
le leader du nouveau parti patriotique a
fait campagne avec un slogan clair plus
en quatre ans de plus le premier mandat
d'accous faut à dos à jeter des bases
sur lesquelles nous construisons le
nouveau ghana le deuxième mandat
d'accous faut à tout va faire rentrer
notre pays dans une ère de prospérité
une ère de progrès in her de
développement une aire d'activité face à
lui john dramani mahama président du
ghana de 2012 à début 2010 est se
présente sous les couleurs du parti
fondé par un autre ancien président
jerry rawlings le congrès démocratique
national
l'homme politique de 62 ans espère
revenir au pouvoir et promet créer plus
d'emplois dans un contexte où la
croissance économique est fortement
touché par la crise sanitaire les deux
rivaux se retrouvent pour un troisième
duel présidentiel qui s'annonce tout
aussi serrée que les deux précédents
leur pacte de paix aura donc une
importance particulière
r les élections consistent à compter les
têtes et non à couper des têtes
nous allons donc oeuvrer à la tenue
d'élections apaisées j'invite les
services de sécurité les électeurs et
toutes les parties prenantes à assurer
le respect de la loi et de l'ordre
public
les élections devrait une nouvelle fois
se dérouler dans le calme contrairement
aux récentes élections en côte d'ivoire
ou au burkina faso marquée par la
contestation
le ghana fait figure d'élève modèle